just like you get a press down those T's
like you wouldn't believe
you know
yeah no no it's just some of these are
better you know you can just like
Titleist flat right I don't know if it's
the flatness it's just you got to push
these guys down you know hello everyone
you're discussing a new computer we got
maybe we'll start using it this week for
the transmissions and I got a keyboard
that you got to press down you know one
of those standalone keyboards not part
of a you know one of these desktop
computers laptops yeah
so we're probably going to be using it
this week anyways
they'll be designing in again one more
time hopefully you're calm laid-back
doing well today
today the chat is about rational science
why am i bringing that subject up well
we've been online now maybe what three
four months I don't even know it made
what my son's on the other side he knows
you know how everyone I think we started
in May no no maybe it was in the way bro
yeah yeah I haven't checked that but I
know we've been around maybe three four
months and and sometimes it's good to
put things in focus otherwise people get
lost maybe go on tangents or whatever
and they say no where's this guy going
with all this yeah tensions are very
good tangents is how you learn true
through you really want to go on
tangents whenever possible but sometimes
you got to bring it all together and try
to make some sense of it you know at
least put it in focus find out you know
what is it all about and and I guess the
first question people might ask is you
know what he caught rational science
isn't science all of it
rational I thought it was right you know
and the answer is no and no second
thoughts about it I'm not even going to
you know apologize
no science is not rational today and
specifically I'm talking about physics
physics is not rational what is called
physics it's actually mathematical
physics absolutely irrational and that's
why we had to put this word rational in
front and you say well what's the
difference between rational science and
I guess traditional science science you
read about every day there you know
maybe you go through the popularization
magazine maybe you're not an expert
maybe you're not a mathematician you say
oh you know I read about you know black
hole space-time particles quantum
particles computers quantum computers
you know obviously and it sounds
rational to me so so let's begin at the
beginning let's be that's a good place
to begin you know the beginning and in
the way it works is that you know if you
go back a hundred years we're talking
about 1920s here right almost a hundred
years
something and I'm sure I don't have
anyone looking at you know watching
these things these videos that is at
least a hundred years old I think that
everyone that watches this came a lot
later than that that means you were born
when when you were born this stuff was
already on there and suddenly you know
you you listen to the stuff you're near
twenty during your 30s you're in your
40s and you listen to this stuff you say
okay quantum mechanics oh yeah Carl
Sagan he great guy you know and you know
Einstein oh he's such a brain he came up
with all this relativity stuff and so on
black holes and dark matter and big bang
now one day you know maybe someone
mentioned something that says oh yeah
space-time oh yeah yeah I heard about
that yes base time as four-dimensional
before dimensional hmm don't quite grasp
it but yeah okay and you know you have
the curvature of space-time and light
curves around there and reaches our eyes
and that's why we can see a star on the
other side of the Sun during an eclipse
something doesn't seem quite right say
what do you mean curved space-time time
time is is a concept you're curving it
and the guy gives you a nonsense answer
he says well in order to understand all
the stuff you really gotta take to an
advanced course in math at the
university I mean you start suspecting
they'll hold it you know time is a
concept I don't think I need to take any
math course at the University to find
out that time is a constant you're
saying that you're warping time yeah
that's exactly what they're saying and
that's when you get your first you know
big bang in your face and then you find
out that you know quantum has all these
fancy explanations a particle can be at
two places at once and it turns into a
wave whenever it wants to and so they
don't call it a party when they don't
call it a way they caught a wave packet
and then you start suspecting and say
something is wrong and then you go to
the forums you know on the internet
maybe and you start discussing physics
your your intuition with some of these
people and they trash you they all gang
up on you you're an idiot
what are you doing here you should take
some math and learn this stuff and now
you go from being a little skeptical to
be a pissed so you hold it you know
something wrong what do you mean I'm
just looking for an explanation you guys
are giving me all this fancy stuff you
know about weird things irrational
things an intuitive counter intuitive
and so at some point you start
questioning if something is wrong
and that's when you come to rational
science because here you get to get an
advanced course in what is wrong out
there not really wrong be we don't call
it wrong we say that's irrational that's
the correct word it's irrational and one
of the things you find out that these
people self admit they confess they tell
you in your fade yeah we know it's
irrational a lot of them do at least I'd
say at least maybe 30 to 40 percent of
the mathematicians out there they'll
tell you oh yeah it's irrational it's
not they'll tell you a little softer
though they'll use some softer word it's
counterintuitive and we don't understand
it quite or it's difficult that's a word
that I've seen also used out there it's
difficult to understand quantum we can
know it's not difficult it's irrational
you'll never understand quantum
mechanics or as mr. Richard Fineman
Nobel Prize what sixteen at five he said
nobody understands quantum mechanics
period we're done after a hundred years
nobody understands quantum mechanics so
it's not difficult it's not just
counterintuitive it's irrational that's
the correct word only idiots believe in
quantum mechanics and so at that point
you say Oh hold it now we're talking
major words here these are words of war
and so you need to get some arguments
under your armpits so that when you go
to a forum you don't get trashed at
least you know how to defend yourself
you know how to attack you know what
what question says what the issues are
and that's what this channel is actually
about in the long run you know this
we're not only interested in educating
people and giving them weapons believe
it's a war he thinks it's AI kids more
cooperatively like we're both we're both
working together to understand the
universe no you
or you're coming with one person dies
what one survives enduring the other one
has to die true because assuming they
take they like your theory right they
just take it it's not it what is that
you know what does that mean what is it
what is that you've recruited someone if
anything yeah yeah yeah we're not
interested in recruiting what we want to
do is give these people good boxing
lessons so when they get on the ring
they can knock the other guy out yes
knockout it just means that they
convince the other guy to not
necessarily the guys sometimes walk out
of the ring he goes to the hospital he
says I'm still the champ I'm still the
champ which is what I told you last time
yeah they insist that they're the champ
because they're they were not convinced
by your argument they don't have any way
to counter your argos the thing that I
don't like about that or that way of
thinking is already eager to get to the
bottom of these things you really have
to put your egos and medals and
authorities so all the emotions at the
door so we can really look at this
logically rationally because if you
start bringing egos into it who's better
who's smarter and all that [ __ ] it's
like okay now now what are we talking
about here okay it kind of derails the
science of it yeah yeah and and I'll
concede that yeah if we're gonna just do
rational science we're going to do
explanations period and that's where we
stop and when we get into emotions and
we get into at hominins and so on then
we get into religion now we're not doing
science anymore in that sense he's
totally right but I defend you so much
the point where it's like it is kind of
a defense in that sense where you're
trying to kind of figure out stable
footing for yourself like how does this
universe or so I can explain it to
myself and when you go to talk to
someone else it kind of is like a fight
because you're bringing what you know
and they're bringing what they know not
know but everything what they memorize
everything that you assume memorize or
believe or or believe by effort through
another believe something you logically
concluded there's a lot on which
a lot of ways to accrue information
right and it's a battle in that sense
where you're both essentially fighting
in a way the ego helps because you're
both defending your if your religion
forget the religion but you're both
defending one of the possible answers to
how mother nature runs our show the best
to your abilities so the ego kind of
helps you like defend the food like you
have position a they align on the
brainstorming yeah one line on the brain
you have one you have let's say there's
ten theories on how mother nature does
like right how light works and how what
like looks like and all that you're
defending a he's defending B and the ego
kind of helps you both defend those to
the death
I mean it's it kind of backfires at
someone because there's like okay you're
defending it too much
now you're going into weird stuff not
now you're not making your making more
emotion it's kind of nice that we have
that you know human nature that defends
our point no matter how dumb is we're
gonna exhaust every possible when you
call it perspective on your point yeah
just just to win the argument forget
about making sense
but then you know in order to begin the
debate with whatever exists today
whatever we have out there quantum
mechanical general relativity string
theory in order to begin the debate
especially from rational science point
of view you got to do two things you got
to define you know first what science is
and second if it's going to be defined
as rational science as we define it then
you got to define both rational and
explanation what do you mean rational
what do you mean explanation looks like
everybody already knows what rational is
what exploration is and it turns out
they don't here I had this gentleman his
name is Pierre Figueroa and he claims to
be a mathematician math teacher at the
high school level and he says he's got a
bachelor's
in both physics and in mathematics and
this would he answered the other day to
my criticism of you know one of the guys
who writes many of the articles in kora
he says the best way to explain
something is often to describe something
and the best way to describe something
is often to explain something obviously
we mean the same things when we use the
terms explain and describe and then he
yeah it's by the way mathematics because
I obviously attacked mathematics right
mathematical physics specifically says
yeah yeah yeah
by the way mathematics is also a science
we can study theorize and prove
mathematical theories I have to explain
in the math class his class right I have
to describe into physics class that was
his answer he had other stuff in there
but the bottom line is he didn't he
couldn't tell the difference between
first description and explanations
second he didn't realize and never
accept it or you know never conceded
that mathematics is about describing and
so I didn't use my words because you
know they say ah that's you invented
that those are your words no no I put a
couple instances there one by Nobel
Prize mr. Steven Weinberg he received
his Nobel Prize I think in 68 there
abouts shortly after or maybe it was in
the seventies I don't know anyways the
point is that Weinberg in YouTube video
that you can look up out there get the
what is it the address he says that
mathematics does not explain he says you
know mathematics only describes and he's
not the only one who says it's someone
else
I always mentioned because he's got it
in his website he's a emeritus professor
at University of Pennsylvania fellow and
his name is Donald semanek and he says
in his glossary
he's got an unlined also he says science
referring to actually in mathematical
physics because that's what he does
science does not explain science
describes so apparently these two
gentlemen at least recognize that
there's a difference between explaining
and description unlike mr. Pierre
Figueroa who apparently teaches high
school students he says obviously we
mean the same things when we use the
terms explain and describe okay so there
is so we so it's not common knowledge
that everybody has that a description is
if somebody and not the same thing as an
explanation every baby is definitely
rare knowledge I mean even we get into
discussions yeah yeah it's there is it
is an easy place to get tripped up yeah
and and that's what you know and again
remember I'm gonna define science as
rational explanations I'm going to
include under the rational part science
physics divided into physics and
philosophy and on the other side where
we have irrational stuff and opinions
and beliefs I'm gonna put it under
religion and so you do have theories on
both sides right but the ones on the
right-hand side on a religious side you
know they're either supernatural or
irrational and there's a difference
supernatural means you can still imagine
the objects you know everybody can
imagine God everyone can imagine an
angel and you can make even maybe make
even a little ghost-like thing and say
that's a spirit or a ghost or whatever
you want to call it that's fine as long
as you put an object there but that's
not what irrational theories do is such
as mathematical physics you know which
include general relativity quantum
mechanics and string theory what these
people do is they turn concepts abstract
concepts into physical objects that's
where we have a problem that's the main
problem okay and so you know so yeah if
science is about doing rational
explanations we have to define both
rational
explanations and you know apparently
this math teacher he doesn't understand
the difference he believes that an
explanation is a description of
descriptions and explanation he can
define either word in terms of the other
and he doesn't see any difference and we
do have to make a distinction if we're
gonna say that descriptions are not a
part of science now what do I mean by
that because some people also get
tripped up there's it's a little tricky
rational science has three steps
hypotheses theory and conclusions
hypothesis includes the descriptions but
that's not science all by itself that's
just a hypothesis what do we mean by
this we mean then first you introduce
the idea for physics for the purposes of
phases first we introduce the objects we
point to them we name them you say this
is a tree there's a dog this is a rock
fine next we define our crucial words
the ones that make or break our theory
okay and the third step within the
hypothesis is that you're going to
describe the initial scene you're not
gonna explain anything just imagine you
know a detective goes to a crime scene
you know he looks at the the whole scene
he says okay this this is what I think
this is what I observed this is the
first thing I saw so you describe the
scene you've sent out a dead body on the
floor and I've stuck to their back etc
etc you describe the scene you still
haven't explained anything you just
described this is what I'm gonna explain
I'm gonna give a theory for how this
person died but the description is only
you know the first step is just you
describe what you saw and I call those
the first frames of the film the initial
frames I call it the statement of the
facts not the facts because the
prosecutor might have a different fact
set of facts than the defense attorney
they might see things a little different
what they saw or how they perceived a
scene so I call it a statement of the
facts only mother nature knows the facts
for sure she knows exactly what happened
we we can only have a statement of what
we think were the facts of what we think
happened or assumptions and that's what
they are they're assumption there that's
what we call the hypothesis just the
assumptions and but that's that science
that's only the first step there you
were pointing at the objects we're
defining terms and we're describing the
initial scene
that's where description comes in that's
it that's where it stops but that's not
science science vibrates in the next
step at the theory level when you have
to explain something and I always use
this example because I think it's quite
very clear you go to the show and you
see the magician cut the lady in half
you know a magician says okay he cut her
into pieces it took him 15 strokes of
the saw took 20 seconds that's a
description science vibrates in time II
how he did the trick how that lady came
up after the curtains closed and open
and she came back as one piece after he
cut her in half we want to know how he
did the trick that's where you have to
break your brain but describing the
scene and saying you know he did in so
much time and so many you know motions
of the saw that's irrelevant
well no it's deeper than that though
uh-huh because with descriptions you can
describe every my new show of everything
he did and the description equals
explanation part is the self-evident
thing there you go oh that's how he did
it with just description you know if I
described everything that if I described
it her and her stomach is under the saw
and her stomach is you know out of the
way and she's not she same I just
described I'm not explaining I in that
sense it's explicit description to
explain because if you describe a scene
enough more precisely enough then the
truth or the explanation becomes
self-evident yeah but first of all you
got to make it explicit and that's not
explicit but that's one issue but
there's a more deeper issue the issue is
that the mathematicians don't get into
qualitative descriptions they only get
into quantitative they say
fifteen 15 strokes of the saw 20 seconds
that's what they say that's the problem
the problem they stop there they don't
go into the part where the lady has ER
but you know under the saw level or
whatever the trick you know there's many
ways of doing that trick I know because
I have a brother who's a magician he
does all these tricks and he creates
tricks for other people and so on and
and so you know they have all these
different ways of doing that same trick
some of them are done with mirrors etc
the point here is that you know you want
to know how they did the trick how they
fooled you how Mother Nature fooled you
that's what you want to know how she
does gravity how she does magnetism how
she does that electricity out she does
atomic level stuff that's what you want
to understand but to say that you know
the electron ways so many kilograms tiny
amount that the Planck length is so long
those are descriptions you haven't
explained anything all you did was
measure different ways you might have to
run experiments you might have to smash
what they think are particles and get
your conclusions from there you can say
I used so much energy and I do this
calculation and I arrived at this length
or at this much energy this much mass oh
you're done is described and an equation
is that an equation is just a
description it's a description of motion
we call it something else I call it a
not a description because I'm saying the
word description really should be used
like when you describe a chair like
static yeah static aesthetic object you
say well you know what is a chair chairs
that's the chair you point and say
that's a chair okay fine we got the
object now you describe you say it's got
four legs two armrests one back one seat
that's a description wanta tative
description but if you want to describe
what we call you know something in
motion we use the word narrate or
narration now you're just you're telling
a little story a little tale but you're
just doing the objective facts like just
the facts ma'am just
facts you're not you're not explaining
anything you're just saying look I'm
just gonna tell you what happened you
know this car ran into the other they
crashed blah blah blah that's it you
haven't explained anything yet you know
and so you have description you have
narration you have explanation and the
description the word description should
only be used for were used adjectives
and apply them to static object whereas
the word narrate or narration should be
used using adverbs and applying to
things in motion and as what I'm
recommending okay if we use them that
way I think we're gonna use them
consistently but the bottom line here is
that you know the first part of the
scientific method the rational
scientific method is the hypothesis and
within that you shouldn't you should
include descriptions or nere
narratives narrations that's it that's
where it should stop explanation
something else now you're gonna tell the
audience how something happened what
caused it to happen you're gonna dis
you're gonna explain a mechanism and
it's gotta be objective you know I pull
on a rope the pulley the little round
thing on the top you know pull the pail
upwards so everybody understand why the
pail went up because you you can
describe or you can make a movie of
every part of what you are explaining
and so people by watching the movie they
can understand they can see how the pill
went up you know you pull down the rope
the little wheel turned around and the
rope was going around it and pulled from
a hook from the you know the pail and
you're done
and people can understand just by
watching the movie that's an explanation
that's a cause of how the pail went up
or an explanation of the mechanism of
how to pull a pail up okay and that's
what we're saying that's the way science
should work the problem here is that the
mathematicians evolved there's no
conspiracy I want you to understand that
I'm not claimed injured there's a
conspiracy out there I'm just saying
that this is the way things develop this
is the way things evolved you had the
19th century mathematicians researchers
and so on they they were in their little
labs you have people all the way from
Michael Faraday and mathematicians such
as James Maxwell you had hertz Lord
Kelvin all these people were
investigating in their little labs there
they were investigating chemistry things
and physics things they were looking at
sound they were looking at electricity
they were looking at you know the
fundamentals especially of the invisible
world the visible world they had pretty
much already
been able to explain but what they
couldn't explain was the invisible world
and after 400 years they still had made
no progress 300 years probably and at
the turn of the century we started
getting into quantum and that's when
things got really out of hand because
people got into they went on a more
abstract and ever more abstract path and
the physics behind and if you look at
the word abstract abstraction it's
exactly the opposite of physical
physical physics is physical abstract is
abstract so if you're going to do
abstractions call it abstraction don't
call it physics and as I pointed out you
know Max Born I think it was 19 26 or 27
there abouts he came up with that idea
that know she says you know physics has
become more and more abstract and from
now it's gonna be from now on it's gonna
be more and more abstract well if it
becomes more and more abstract it
becomes it gets farther and farther away
from physics because physics is physical
and abstraction is abstract they're
opposites what has happened is that the
abstraction part is mathematics that's
what it is and so what what has evolved
not again no conspiracy just the way
it's evolved
is that the science has become physics
and physics has become abstract and so
they explain everything with
abstractions what does this mean it
means they're gonna use mathematics and
what does that mean that means they're
going to be using mathematical objects
whatever that means to you so all these
so-called words that they inherited from
the 19th century which were inherited
even from before then words like such as
mass energy force-field best Liefeld
time all these words became physical
objects they they were used as physical
objects people began to warp time and
they became to move a mass and they
began to transfer energy these are the
the terms they used and you're saying
holy what do you mean transfer energy
what did you transfer you transfer the
concept because energy is a concept it's
not a physical object but they're
treating it if all there were in other
presentation all their dissertations
they're treating it as a physical object
when you try to criticize that they say
ah you're you're you're raising
semantics semantics all arguments so
they don't consider that physic physics
is just a math and when you say it's
also a rational and say well we know
that we can and you say what do you mean
you know that it's irrational yeah we
can't understand this universe how it
works or they'll give you an answer such
as you know we cannot expect humans with
our rationality with our level of
rationality to understand it doesn't
match the universe's rationality so we
can't ever comprehend the universe all
we can do is try to approach it from the
angle of math and what does this does in
the end is say look we've declared that
physics in other words ie you know that
is science is the same thing as math and
math is the only way to approach and
understanding quotations their underwear
understanding of the universe and we
know it's irrational we know we can't
understand it in physical terms we
cannot explain it using ordinary speech
or ordinary language or verbs to
straightforward English we have to only
understand it through the language of
math through the language of physics or
the language of science which is
mathematics and that's kind of a
self-serving circular issue these people
are saying you know math is science
sciences math math is the language of
science and science cannot do without
math that's what they're saying and
you're saying well you skipped
rationality you you bypass you skipped
over that and they said well we can't
understand the universe we can never
hope to understand the universe we don't
even try because that's not science
that's ontology that's metaphysics
that's who knows what it is it's
semantics it's not science and that's
where we have a problem because we're
saying oh no no no no if I have gravity
I drop a pen let go of a pen and it
falls to the floor I got to be able to
explain that and these people say you'll
never be able to explain it we can only
describe it mathematically and science
is description and that's where we put
the word rational why because if you go
to the quantum world well you find
nonsense like this for example you let
see if I can get it here what is a
particle a particle is an excited state
of a field so what is a field a field is
a mathematical entity and a quantum
field is what you get when you quantize
a classical field that's it did you
understand everything in other words
what these people are saying look a
particle is not what you thought was a
part it was a field turns out when you
look up the word field it's a concept it
was defined by Michael Faraday he
originally started using these term this
term around the 35 1835 1830
six maybe in the 40s but for sure in the
50s because he wrote about in 50s but
he's already logged in the philosophical
Society of England
all right into 40 45 46 he's already
been using those words field eventually
he formalized it and so did especially a
Maxwell you know he used that word field
also he just bottled it borrowed it from
faraday and started using it and they
had to define that word and they said
look it's a it's a region that's what
field means eventually ultimately it's a
field is a region it's a potential at
each point in space around an object and
they apply to do initially to electric
and magnetic fields eventually it was
looked it up and I couldn't figure out
when who was the first one to apply it
to gravity officially because Newton
already referred to it he already more
or less described what a gravitational
field is but it was then someone used it
formally in the 19th century and I don't
know who that first person was but they
started using the word gravitational
field or gravity field as well so they
had the field for magnetism they had a
field for electricity and they had a
field for gravity and what are they
talking about well they're talking about
a potential at each point in space in a
region around an object that's all
they're saying again a concept it's not
a physical lab you can't take a field
and say look here is a field oh let me
draw it for you let me this is a
standalone object I'm gonna bring a
statue of a field to the conference you
can't do that field is something that
belongs to something else
it's a halo that surrounds something
that's all the field is but they turned
this field into a physical standalone
physical object they start moving around
they talk about the field that the field
extends all the way to the edges of the
universe for every single particle in
existence muon you get a muon field
Payan you got a Payan field electron you
add an electron field
every particle that you know photon you
got a photon field so for every particle
that you can name there's a field and
and all these fields kind of superimpose
up on each other they don't seem to
trouble each other at all and that's how
they use them because they use them for
the purposes of math that's all they're
they're thinking of math or thinking of
equations and that's the issue the issue
is they use these words but they use
them as physical object and you say look
you can't use in fact here I have the
criteria I would have it whereas it here
it is you have the irrational criteria
for for any if you want to challenge any
theory you have irrational criteria the
first one is the one I'm referring to
converting concepts into physical
objects if you convert a concept into
physical objects you are beat you have
an irrational theory if you say that
love moves mountains if you say
poetically no problem but if you really
mean in physics that love pushes
mountains aside then you got our serious
problem and using undefined words it's
the next one then you have converting
you know the theory doesn't follow from
the from the description or assumptions
and the last one is that you you
describe and you claim to have explained
those are a sense the the criteria for
arash for irrationality and we're
referring to rational theories again we
clarify that you know even though
there's a tendency to apply them to
people you're saying I'm you you're
gonna attack the theory you're gonna say
look your theory is irrational if you
believe it you are irrational but you
shouldn't mention that you know the
point is you know the we have criteria
and people might say well you know but
that's your opinion you you created
those criteria and so the answer to that
is what's wrong with it you have a
problem with any of them is it rational
to use a concept as an object I mean if
we're talking about physics we're gonna
be moving objects around hopefully
physics
not be done without objects and a good
guy brings in you know a concept like
energy and she uses it as an object you
brings another field another concept and
uses it as an object or the word mass
another concept uses it as an object
isn't that irrational and if the guy you
know admits are confessing well yeah
that's irrational it's pertinent because
it relates to objects and objects is
what physics is about so the guys using
a concept that's an object there there
should be no question for that criterion
and if he doesn't you know if he has no
objection to it it stands he can add
more stuff if he comes up with another
way of you know another criterion and he
says look you know if you do this this
and that that's also irrational okay
let's add it but you can't take this one
away because you have no objection to
this criterion I did not come out of
this you know out of one day I had a
headache and I came up with it I started
thinking you know what do we mean by
rational a rational theory and these are
the criteria and came up with and so now
you can apply this to a guy who says oh
but that's your personal opinion okay
what do you have against them
please come hit me with everything you
got show me that this is not a valid
criterion for physics in a way you kind
of hope that's kind of what you do to
yourself when you come up with a new
idea you flog yourself hey you know
postulate something okay how about how
about this just let's assume this and
then you throw everything you can to
dismiss what you just put up to see if
it stands it's like brainstorming yeah
but but it's the second step to
brainstorming cuz brainstorming is okay
let's put everything on the board that
we knew they made right right and then
what you do is bye-bye
you call it trial and error or
elimination process of elimination of
you go one by one you start at the top
you go okay how about this one what's
wrong with this possibility and you
basically go through them until you find
the one with the least wrong with the
least flaws that essentially often goes
back to Occam's razor
yeah where you say okay the fifth one
had the least amount of flaws or the
least amount of holes potholes there
might be one this is better than that
but I haven't thought of it I haven't
put it on the list on the list so we
didn't think with the best I could come
up with but when you're talking to
someone else or when you give your
theory to someone else and say okay what
can you tell me that I haven't already
shot at my own theory right you kind of
get bored if they say things that you've
already thought of they okay now I just
got to educate this person because he
hasn't thought it as deeply as I have
but they come with something no that's
like oh I didn't think about that one no
I have something to think about but
again you know the issue here is that
you you provide these criterion criteria
and it's up to the other person to shoot
him down and if he has no argument
against them you know what is he gonna
do he can add to it but obviously cannot
subtract any of these because they are
pertinent to physics first and second I
think they're straightforward you can't
use a concept as an object because that
would be irrational and and so you know
just for your information I have put
these criteria out there in Cora
and people who you know see their
religion being threatened they come in
and I said okay what do you got show me
what you got and not one could not one
came up and say this is you should take
that criterion out because I you know
because it's not appropriate or it's not
valid it's just your opinion not one has
come out so far everybody's and you know
and I think it'll remain that way they
have no arguments to bring against this
these are valid criteria for rationality
and so that that's the part of
rationality what is an explanation and
again I showed that you know some people
confuse the description for an
explanation that's a serious problem
because if a descriptions an explanation
let me tell you where the danger
is mathematics comes in says oh we
describe which is what they do which is
the only thing they do so we're doing
science because if rational explanations
is converted in to rational descriptions
then they're okay right and that's where
the danger is I'm saying explanations
not description rational explanations
what science does but rational
descriptions is what mathematics does
and has nothing to do with science never
heard rational description yeah well
that's what once an irrational this
group an equation that is wrong that's
an equation that is not proper 1 plus 1
plus 2 equal 4 that's an irrational
description irrational or adding an
adjective to a verb stuff like that
that's from a qualitative point of view
but it from a mathematical point of view
you know uh negative time which is what
Stephen Hawking invented negative time
what is that yeah going back yeah I mean
you know they invent all these concepts
out there some are so weird that it's
not even worth analyzing but the point
is you know you know they are we gonna
say that science is rational
descriptions is that what science is
just describing that the mathematician
that the magician cut the lady in half
and so many strokes and so much time
that's it
yeah it's ok so it's rational and it's a
description is that science or a better
mark more than the point example is
would be the explanation for magnetism
saying that the to saying that North
attracts out or that the two pulled each
other or they repel each other at
such-and-such speed that's not enough we
want to know why they do that right and
not not why they have that speed
although that might be a separate
question we want to know the qualitative
what is the actual thing that makes them
pull on each other yeah what is what is
the invisible that's going on in there
like show it to me
don't don't don't just tell me that they
do or how fast they do or or what the
effects are like okay
we got the effects down pat now can we
explain these effects the the [ __ ]
another German word wishbone the cause
the mechanism era but like the beginning
the the source the source of the short
eggs okay I don't know what is the
source of these effect we know the
effects we don't do it to you and on the
amount of the effect you know the range
of the effect we know everything about
the effect we get it yeah we've
described the effect to death but can we
explain the source of the effect and
that's where modern science has come up
short and beyond that they've just
abandoned the causes entirely completely
no in fact they don't know what gravity
is yeah I mean brevity is is is a good
example
okay now you want that blows my mind to
this day that's something that no one
kind of that's not common knowledge that
if you walk around yeah oh yeah we don't
know what gravity is no no one says yeah
but no one no one walks around thinking
that phrase we don't know what gravity
is but no one knows what gravity is what
it like we all know the effects of grab
right right well we don't know what it
is
no in fact imagine gravity for two
seconds you know you get something you
let go of it right and it falls to the
ground right and we've seen there
million times so we don't need to know
what speed it fell what the acceleration
why what the my seconds what the what
the mass of this is we want to know the
mechanism and everybody's familiar with
gravity I think you know since you're a
baby you start learning stuff about
gravity but when you drop your of the
effects of yeah yeah in other words it's
the thing we're all because the effects
is where the use comes from yeah where
the how do we use gravity how do we use
magnetism that's what that's when the
effects play what technology can we make
with these things know what use can we
can we have with these phenomena for
everyday life that is pertaining to the
effects but the useless part which is
explaining the source of the effects or
why these effects are the way they are
without just saying that's just how they
are like trying to uh trying to assume
or just imagine you not make effect
failure
nation trying to use our imagination say
okay if there were an invisible shape
moving these things what would that
shape be what would be the motions of
this shape load
what would the invisible look like you
have to make an assumption that's kind
of the useless part that everyone throws
aside because you have no use for that
like okay okay you know it doesn't help
me knowing that gravity's a rope if I
already know all the effects of the Rope
yeah but the the advantage there is the
following that we have a different view
of the universe if we if we like in the
case of the rope hypothesis if all atoms
are interconnected we have a totally
different universe if that's the
explanation now we say I'll hold it so
all this stuff that we've been doing for
the last hundred years discrete
particles just banging against each
other all this wiped away and now we
have a different kind of universe and
that's when people start opening their
eyes because the universe I was born
with like different kind of universe
like we changed it so yeah this we're
all connected has always been used
metaphorically but never literally where
every single atom in the universe was
connected to each other by it
it's a voltage it's a completely
different paradigm from which to build
everything all your other beliefs it's
kind of one of those Brown beliefs and
it may it I don't know you know
obviously people whose minds will start
rolling and as oh look I can do some
technology with this now that I
understand this invisible world they
might I offer all I know they care you
know I'm not into technology at all so I
don't care about that side of of what
goes out there in the world today I just
care about the theoretical stuff I limit
myself to science technology is a
different story you know I work in
technology many years and I respect it
and it's a different field totally
different field and I liked it I did my
stuff there but you know I'm into
something else I'm into science and
technology you can say oh now that I
know that how this yeah that light is a
rope and magnet
the swinging of threads and electricity
is you know this serpentine that's
turning around in situ you know that's a
different world and maybe the guy takes
that and because of that comes up with
an idea and says oh I'm gonna develop
this device start exploring a a
trial-and-error that hasn't been
explored right and he might be able to
to develop or invent some new technology
for all I know you know that's fine but
that's not the purpose the purpose is to
explain at the sea of different kind of
universe if the universe is as quantum
and general relativity proposed quantum
says you know all particles are discrete
we bang them we get more particles and
we give them new names period that's it
that's all that's all of quantum right
there synthesized in two seconds what is
general relativity well we have you know
Big Bang that's how the universe was
created
we have black holes maybe Big Bang
itself our universe is a black hole for
all we know there's theories on that
dark matter how does a galaxy rotate
because it's got all this dark matter on
the outside and all that vanishes if if
we have a different you know
if all if all atoms are interconnected
so all that world now changes completely
say hey we wipe all this thing out that
we've been believing for the last
hundred years and now we have a new
universe now we're talking about
something else why does Andromeda get
pulled towards the Milky Way well
because all atoms over there are
connected to every atom over here now
that's a different story
that's not what we've been told for so
many years so many years we've been
doing on it all with math math and mass
at the at the cosmic level there's only
mass there's time they've got no other
variables so they say mass how much mass
well it's got more mass it's got less
mass and that's why it attracts that's
why it does this and why it does that
and they use it use it only from a
mathematical point of view and they say
well you need to take a course in math
to understand you know what we're
proposing of course because they cannot
explain it in rational
they cannot make a movie of mass they
cannot make a movie of energy of field
of time they cannot they cannot put
these words into on the screen so they
put objects there but they say disregard
the objects think about the math the
equation see this comes together by such
a such equation this does this because
of such in such equation and you said
but is that the abbe don't worry about
the object oh forget about the object
the object is incidental we just need
something near for you to visualize so
they're not doing physics with objects
they're doing physics with math
placeholders yeah they're placeholders
and they're using words such as point
line you know abstractions not real lobs
at their mathematical objects they're
using concepts as physical objects
energy mass field time force you carry a
force you carry an interaction you
drastically things that you can't
imagine yeah that sounds like a
euphemism you can't imagine it no no I
don't mean it like you can't imagine
like this is what happened and you can
play the movie oh basically okay let's
assume these are the things happen would
everything fit you you play the movie of
you know before the murder happens
everything that leads up to it and then
the murdering you okay then you kind of
when you play the movie you can see
where the flaws are where the flaws
aren't but if they say if the detective
says you know fourth dimension or
something I'll okay now what am I
supposed to what's the what's the thing
that how do I play that movie how do I
add that to the movie you know just
imagine a detective bringing to the
prosecutor the case right say okay we
figured out what happened and now the
the prosecutors gonna explain it to the
jury he says look the robber entered to
the window he stole all the money from
the
the vault he killed the owner of the
house and he escaped through the fourth
dimension what would you think
he disappeared that's where the police
can't find this guy now what do you
think you would do you see he skipped
from through the fourth dimension yeah
he escaped through a wormhole now what
do you think you would think if you're a
juror you know sitting on this 12 jury
12-man jury what would you think of it
uh if someone told you something like
that would you would you say well this
is a rational here I see where we could
catch him he went to the fourth I
mentioned but that make sense for your
invoking kind of a different notion what
you're saying how that's more because
wormholes we don't see them on earth I
mean I can say he fell into a black hole
no no but listen they're afraid that
many people out there are afraid in fact
this is what they're trying to do
they're trying to create a black hole at
some of these accelerators they're
saying look you know what is what is a
particle after it's a field and what is
a field field it's just a question of
how much mass you have in there every
particle in a sense is a black hole in
in in the sense that it's just a
question of size and mass how much
volume and how much yeah that's all it
is so they're trying to grin or one of
the dangers that people think is that
they might create a black hole by
mistake in one of these accelerators the
world right and so you can easily say
look you know I know what happened the
robber escaped through a black hole
straight through a wormhole he went to
the fourth dimension I can say anything
would you believe something like that
because we don't see black holes in the
real world but if someone said the star
went into a black hole then ever all the
jurors would be like oh but this is this
is so weird I mean you're gonna believe
that the star was eaten by a black hole
but you're gonna believe that the robber
the robber
black hole that point we're just talking
about the location of the bike we don't
see them on earth but we see them in
space okay but I mention completely
different thing about completely
unimaginable where you have space time
where I say okay what is the thing that
I I don't even imagine the effects of
that yeah but look the fourth dimension
exists here on earth as well after a few
years that's the point the point is
these people are saying you know the
fourth dimension is here maybe a black
hole is not maybe a wormhole is not but
certainly the fourth dimension is
throughout I mean every every event in
space-time is four-dimensional so I went
through the fourth time minute I went
through the dimension of time and I went
to the future of the past I mean they
say you can travel through the future
not to the past but yes to the future
that's confirmed that's already been
proven so why can't I say yeah I went
through the fourth dimension to the
future that's that's how this guy
escaped he's two steps ahead of us he's
he's two seconds ahead of us he's in the
future I mean if you told that to the
jury what would you if you're a juror
what would you think I mean these are
types of explanations these people give
you and it's like unset a minute ago you
know we we have no problem believing
that a star is swallowed by a black hole
but when you say this guy the robber
went through the fourth dimension he's
in the future and that's why we can't
find them people start saying well I
don't know about that that's where it
becomes three more to the point and I
know let's say I see the robber escaped
into the banana dimension no one talks
about the banana dimensions because I
just made it up no no no he knows he's
an invention right and assume yay I told
that to the juror they'd at least ask
okay what is the banana dimension
they're not just gonna be like oh yeah
because no one's heard of it right right
right right you have it like let's just
let's explain that's the time so you
have to explain what you're talking
about as if they've never has if they
were an alien like no no the answer no
the answer is very clear
what whip the robber actually did know
as if they've never hurt lino if I say
the robber escaped into the banana
dimension I have to explain that in a
way that they've never heard of the
banana dimension no the prosecutor he's
a mathematician he said well you got to
take a college course to understand what
the banana and dine mention is yeah
that's the answer that doesn't help them
but then people say oh because he's you
know he's a college graduate he's got a
PhD so that's why he knows about the
banana and I mentioned I don't because
I'm just a measly old juror you know who
works at at the laundry shop and you
know they gave me they told me I had to
come here for jury duty and yeah I don't
know about the banana they mentioned so
you know I have to accept it on on D on
the knowledge of the prosecutor who's of
the genius that's a good point how do
they do it in a in a court of law
when they have something they can be
rational no no no he goes over the
jurors heads that we have specific cases
there the the mother killed the child
because God or the spirit or the devil
came into her body and instructed her to
do that
and it wasn't her fault it's just that
she was instructed to do that came into
her brain and and just said kill kill
yeah because he's got the devil in him
you have to kill him and because if you
let this child grow he will become the
devil whatever so you explain that to
the jury what do you think the jury will
do they'll say put her in a nuthouse
yeah but I mean it's gonna be pretty
know because he can be very difficult
for the jury in general for the 12 at
least for the 12 of them you know to you
unanimous and say oh poor women I can
see what happened you know where they're
all Christians yeah but even even with
Krita be delighted
most jurors probably heard Christians
anyway but none of em won't believe that
story yeah you say flattered they're all
flat earthers yeah they don't understand
oh yeah I understand that you know flat
earth the point here is you know
to wrap it up you know what we're saying
is rational science we use the word
rational in front because it has to
follow that criteria rational science
rational explanations what is in
explanations it's not a description and
explanations a theory and it has to be
objective and rational what is rational
well what is not irrational
what is irrational anything related to
converting concepts into objects not
defining your terms are using them
inconsistently and third one you know
you know the theory doesn't follow from
the assumptions I put a fourth one in
there that they treat descriptions as
explanations and those are I think valid
criteria you can take some out of you it
can justify it you can put some in if
you can justify or in a nutshell you're
rational science is science by these
rules that's yeah that's amore otherwise
you're not doing right some more that's
more to the point way of saying it we're
gonna call rational science any any
anything that follows these rules if
you're not following these rules then
you're not doing well we call rational
science and what mathematical physics
does is perhaps rational descriptions
the quantitative description and for
sure for sure 100% sure or 150 percent
sure they do irrational explanations
because they all 99.99 I think it's more
it's like 120 percent of the theories
coming out of mathematical physics are
you know especially for the invisible
phenomena 150 percent of them are
irrational because they use
consciousness objects those are the
criteria and with that we're gonna see
you tomorrow
and hopefully tomorrow we'd like to
touch on a subject we left off last week
and I'm not gonna mention it will give
you a little surprise if you still
remember what it was about so we'll see
you tomorrow same time same station
we'll see you then
bye bye